buongiorno a tutti sono gay
sì sono una psicologa
e una sessuologa di cosa vorrei parlarvi
oggi dell'abbigliamento come strumento
per aumentare il nostro capitale oggi
parliamo di crescita per aumentare la
nostra crescita ma soprattutto il nostro
benessere il nostro capitale di per star
bene nella mia pratica clinica mi sono
sempre occupata di persone che appunto
non stanno bene e mi sono sempre più
resa conto che sicuramente importante
aiutare le persone a togliere il
malessere ma è altresì vero che talvolta
è ancora più importante aiutare le
persone a stare meglio e quindi mi sono
chiesta quali possono essere gli
strumenti per stare bene
tra questi strumenti io credo che il
l'abbigliamento abbia un potere
assolutamente importante per parlare di
questo o due premesse teoriche su cui
posso fermarmi parlando di benessere gli
economisti hanno sempre detto che tutti
noi disponiamo di tre forme di capitale
il capitale economico ovvero le nostre
finanze il capitale relazionale
ne parlavamo prima è proprio legato alle
relazioni che noi abbiamo nella nostra
capacità di stare con gli altri
il capitale culturale e quello che noi
sappiamo ma nel 2010 una sociologa dice
c'è una quarta forma di capitale il
capitale erotico che cos'è il capitale
erotico è sedato da sei componenti non è
la bellezza la bellezza fisica la
chiarezza la luminosità e la simmetria
in termini proprio classici del termine
e su questo non possiamo farci niente
ma ci sono altre cinque variabili sulle
quali possiamo investire proprio per
aumentare il nostro benessere e possiamo
invertire attraverso l'abbigliamento
quali sono queste cinque forme di
variabili che influenzano il capitale
erotico 1 e sex appeal e si dice se la
bellezza viene identificata in una
fotografia e sex appeal e invece si vede
in un video il sex appeal e il fascino
lo charme fatto che una persona
comunichi una sua dimensione di bellezza
anche interiore poi abbiamo la vivacità
ovvero la voglia di vivere e il fatto
che una persona sia energica che ci
comunichi la sua energia
poi abbiamo le competenze sociali ovvero
la nostra capacità di stare con gli
altri di stare bene con gli altri
poi abbiamo lo stile nell'apparire
ovvero quello che proprio si racconta
con l'abbigliamento e infine abbiamo le
competenze sessuali il nostro
immaginario erotico la nostra capacità
di soddisfare sessualmente il patner
quindi il capitale erotico e qualcosa
sul quale possiamo investire per
aumentare il nostro benessere come
attraverso l'abbigliamento seconda
dimensione teorica e quella legata
all'autostima
noi possiamo pensare che l'autostima sia
fondamentalmente molto strettamente
correlata alla traenza perché perché è
vero che ci diciamo che non è così
necessario essere belli cerchiamo di
sottovalutarlo ma è altresì vero che la
nella nostra vita abbiamo imparato che
quanto più piacciamo e ci piacciamo
quanto più abbiamo una sensazione di
stare meglio con noi stessi e di nuovo
appunto aumentiamo il nostro capitale di
benessere in una società dove
l'autostima e la traenza sono
strettamente correlate perché abbiamo
una cultura del bello dove tutti
raccontano che è necessario essere belli
e credo importante far rivedere
velocemente questa questi dati del
psycology today che nel 1972 raccontava
che il 23 per cento delle donne rene
soddisfatte della propria apparenza
arriviamo nel 1997 dove le donne
insoddisfatte del proprio aspetto sono
il 56 per cento e probabilmente se
psicologi today facessi un'altra
indagine adesso
racconterebbe che la percentuale di
donne insoddisfatte del proprio aspetto
e ancora maggiore anche gli uomini sono
insoddisfatti di loro e soprattutto la
cosa che voglio sottolineare di qua e
che nel corso del tempo via via che la
cultura cresce aumenta sempre più la
cultura del bel bello per cui le persone
hanno degli ideali di bellezza
particolarmente elevati da raggiungere è
la sensazione di insoddisfazione
personale sempre maggiore perché noi
aspiriamo ad essere sempre più belli di
quello che sia possibile essere nelle
donne poi l'insoddisfazione rispetto al
proprio peso continua a crescere quindi
la dimensione esse non sono magra non mi
piaccio e quindi che perché vi sto
dicendo questi dati perché nel momento
in cui non mi piaccio la mia autostima
scende nel momento in cui la mia
autostima e scende la mia sensazione di
benessere scende e così vi vostro questo
grafico questo grafico mostra
l'andamento dell'autostima nel corso
della vita di uomini e donne e gli
uomini sono la linea più alta le donne
sono la linea più bassa che cosa ci dice
questo grafico tra l'altro di una
ricerca del 2020 molto recente che tra i
9 ei 12 anni uomini donne partono con lo
stesso livello di autostima
poi c'è una calo importante per le donne
dell'autostima anche per gli uomini ma
per le donne ancora molto più importante
è finalmente le donne hanno una risalita
dell'autostima dopo i 50 anni
questo perché perché inizialmente
finalmente a 50 anni una donna ma anche
gli uomini si rendono conto che il
proprio valore non risiede solo
nell'apparenza nella fetta dai 15 anni
ai 50 anni
la propria autostima è fortemente
correlata alla propria apparenza e la
propria bellezza e quindi la propria
sensazione di benessere scende nella
misura in cui scende l'autostima quindi
arriviamo al vivo del mio discorso come
l'abbigliamento possa essere strumento
per aumentare il nostro capitale erotico
e per aumentare la nostra autostima
attraverso la traenza e l'abbigliamento
lo può fare questa cosa attraverso
due sistemi 1 attraverso l'immagine che
ho di me l'altro è lo vedremo attraverso
l'immagine che io do agli altri
in che modo l'abbigliamento incide
sull'immagine che ho di me e incide sul
mio benessere
parliamo qui vien clothing commission
che cos'è l'intero team commission è
diciamo un costrutto teorico che è stato
identificato allorché due scienziati
hanno fatto questo esperimento hanno
dato immaginiamo che lo possa fare anche
con voi questo esperimento a due gruppi
di persone assolutamente eterogenei tra
di loro due camici in realtà era lo
stesso camicie solo che a un primo
gruppo veniva detto che era il camice di
un imbianchino al secondo gruppo il
camice di un medico
dopo di che veniva chiesto ai tuoi
gruppi di trovare le differenze come un
compito della settimana enigmistica
ecco il gruppo che indossava un camice
da medico trovava molte più differenze
rispetto al gruppo che indossava il
camice da imbianchino
questo perché perché l'esperienza fisica
di indossare un certo capo e la
dimensione simbolica che questo capo ci
rappresenta
ci fa sentire diversi quindi se io
indosso l'abito sapendo che il camice di
un medico mi sento più importante trovo
più differenze analoghe ricerche sono
state fatte per esempio sugli studenti
universitari ragazze in costume ragazze
in tailleur e debbano fare un compito di
matematica trovano molte più hanno una
miglior performance quando appunto
indossano il tie ore rispetto al costume
quindi ci stiamo dicendo che a seconda
del nostro abbigliamento addirittura
abbiamo potenziate le nostre capacità
cognitive ma non solo abbiamo potenziate
le nostre capacità cognitive abbiamo
potenziato anche la nostra le nostre
performance con comportamentali sin da
bambini a si è visto questa cosa nei
bambini dell'asilo se è un bambino dopo
pranzo si è sporcato è una patacca
adulto sulla maglietta
dopo pranzo interagisce molto di meno
con i propri coetanei perché si sente a
disagio e tutti voi credo che abbiate
esperito questa cosa per cui nel momento
in cui non stavate bene con il vostro
abbigliamento stavate male con voi
stessi e poi quindi con gli altri
ugualmente venditori al telefono che
quindi non avevano un immagine che
veniva vista in tailleur o in tuta
vendevano molto di più quando innata io
rispetto a quando in tuta quindi di
nuovo possiamo dire che l'abbigliamento
incide anche sulle nostre competenze
comportamentale infine l'abbigliamento
influenza anche le nostre emozioni
quindi cognizioni comportamenti ed
emozioni
in che modo influenza le nostre emozioni
in tanto è vero che esiste una b di
razionalità per cui se io ho un certo
tipo di emozione mi vestirò in un certo
modo
se sono triste mi vestirò in qualche
modo non mi curerò nel mio vestire se
sono felice mi vestirò in maniera più
curata e quindi sarò ancora più felice
addirittura negli anni 50 si era parlato
di fashion hunter apice dell'utilizzo
dell'abbigliamento per aiutare le
persone che soffrivano di depressione e
rispetto questo a proposito
dell'importanza anche delle emozioni vi
mostro questa immagine
in questa immagine c'è la stessa donna
raffigurata che indossa in un caso un
abito molto appariscente nel secondo
caso un abito comodo in un terzo caso un
abito dismesso provate a indovinare in
quale di queste immagini la donna
indossa un abito appariscente volete
provare a pensarci è giusto cioè che
cosa si dimostra in questo esperimento
che il fatto di indossare un certo abito
lì non lo vediamo che abito indossa ci
fa sentire in un certo modo e quindi la
comunicazione non verbale anche del suo
sguardo di questa persona ci racconta
che questa persona sta bene con se
stesso e con il proprio abbigliamento
quindi ci siamo detti che
l'abbigliamento può influenzare i nostri
comportamenti i nostri le nostre
emozioni addirittura le nostre
performance cognitive migliorando
lo stesso e aumentando il nostro
capitale di benessere ma poi c'è
un'altra parte che su cui gioca
l'abbigliamento ovvero quella in cui
l'abbigliamento ha un ruolo
sull'immagine che io do di me agli altri
e non solo da un'immagine di me agli
altri ma gli altri interagiscono con me
a seconda dell immagine che di me hanno
qui dobbiamo parlare di quello che è
l'effetto what is what is good effetto
ovvero ciò che è bello è anche buono in
altre parole tutto quello che noi
vediamo come bello secondo noi ha più
valore e quando questo si rifà alle
persone pensiamo che le persone belle
sono anche le persone con più valore
ma la domanda è belle o con un capitale
erotico e la risposta è con un buon
capitale erotico hanno fatto diversi
esperimenti una modella molto bella non
curata una modella meno bella più curata
che doveva vendere dei profumi la
modella meno bella ma molto più curata
riusciva a vendere molto di più rispetto
alla modella bella ma non curata 15
stiamo dicendo che nel momento in cui
noi influenziamo nel nostro
abbigliamento riusciamo in qualche modo
ad apparire meglio rispetto agli altri
ea esercitare negli altri
un comportamento più positivo nei nostri
confronti per esempio persone vestite
nello stesso modo
ricevono per esempio la la possibilità
di comunicare meglio con gli altri
quando per esempio tra i corridori
quelli che fanno la corsa sono vestiti
nello stesso modo hanno maggiori
interazioni oppure persone vestite
diverse che hanno commesso lo stesso
reato ricevono delle pene diverse le
cameriere al ristorante ricevono delle
mance più alte quando maggiormente
curate le persone
che vanno a comprare sono avvicinati dai
in qualsiasi tipo di negozi sono
avvicinati dai commessi quando
maggiormente curate 15 stiamo dicendo
che attraverso il nostro abbigliamento e
noi possiamo anche potenziare il
comportamento degli altri rendendolo più
positivo nei nostri confronti
concludo raccontandovi quest ultimo
esperimento in cui una donna in realtà
due donne che non sono particolarmente
piacevoli hanno proposto la loro
candidatura mettendo questa fotografia
sul curriculum solo che vediamo in una
fotografia
l'immagine di una donna truccata
nell'altra la stessa donna non truccata
ecco la fotografia posta sul curriculum
che portava l'immagine di una donna
curata ha ottenuto molto più possibilità
di avere un colloquio di selezione per
altro per un posto di lavoro molto
elevato mentre la donna che non era
truccata la stessa donna non ha ricevuto
la possibilità di fare selezione quindi
sono in chiusura riassumendo quello che
vi ho detto vi ho detto possiamo
investire sul nostro benessere lo
possiamo fare attraverso l'abbigliamento
e lo può fare
aumentando il capitale erotico e
aumentando la nostra autostima perché
l'abbigliamento funziona su due binari
sia l'immagine che ho di me che posso
potenziare che mi può piacere sia
l'immagine che io do agli altri di me
influenzandone gli altri un
comportamento più positivo nei miei
confronti
e così ho concluso grazie